The main video is pulling a bit of a trick at this moment.
The rate the advertisers pay per 1000 views is actually a lot higher than this
and if you own a YouTube channel you can look at your analytics and you'll see a number
listed that's much bigger per 1000.
This is because there are lots of YouTube views where no ad is shown at all.
If you find that hard to believe it's probably because you're
in a prime demographic that advertisers want, so you're always seeing ads on YouTube.
But there are demographics that rarely see ads.
Plus, YouTube normally doesn't show someone an ad when they first arrive on the site.
Channels can have 30 or 40%, or as much as 90% of their views play
without an ad because viewers are in an age or location that fewer advertisers want.
Or, just fewer advertisers happen to be around.
But if you make a YouTube channel, the number you really care about
is the one that's the size of the check that you get divided by your thousands of views.
This is the number creators compare with each other,
even though YouTube doesn't really want us to.